Kevin Hart I love Kevin Hart I love him
I'm know Kevin for a long time right
but Kevin's brand now is like work hard
and and believe in yourself and you can
accomplish whatever you want that's not
real that's what does irresponsible your
motto give me your motivational time
just be at the right place at the right
time we were talking about that today
it's all luck it's all luck like like
trust me if Dave Chappelle hadn't taken
off for South Africa uh-huh and Chris
Tucker hadn't found Jesus Kevin Hart may
not be working that's the truth okay
he doesn't acknowledge having any but
that's the truth Thunder stores there's
thunderstorms you guys ready stay home
don't go out it's raining it's just
being you I want to go to my safe place
I love you guys and I like yeah yeah
uh-huh
let's start properly I look like before
steroids this is America for you right
here makeup on the hole do these look
alike
[Applause]
you know we finally did we finally
invented porn no one will watch so what
is it how do I just pour it in and just
drink you can have a sip with me so
doesn't for out a friend told me how to
do it
alright this is my first shoot those are
my only schooi theatre tomorrow night in
sydney character from the audience you
guys
there was a period where women were like
and that I think it's still there but
like sex in the city came out and when
we're like yeah I like to [ __ ] oh I
could see that and now we're in control
of our own [ __ ] and that scared the
[ __ ] out of me cuz I'm only have sex
with six people women why the same
people what women [ __ ] adult women -
don't women your daughter 14 and 12 they
both had their periods if that's what
you're asking
oh we can't talk about this no no I
can't make it really clear that's not
what I was is that somebody told me if a
bear ever attacks you all you have to do
is pinch his nipples is this true or did
you not know that do you know first of
all is the most brilliant thing in the
world sorry for great you have the
softest skin I can't believe this is our
first time meeting I couldn't imagine
our next time like my wife's got hers at
a football game wearing white pants oh
my god no it was an Alabama football
game so her dad was like she believed
school colors roll time you've got
beautiful young daughters messing my
eyes are you gonna tell your daughters
about your record do you have like a
plaque at home saying goodbye the best
partier my daughters are so stupid don't
worry about them read many fake
[Applause]
I dated a girl that was so dumb
one time she was literally the dumbest
chick she was afraid to eat pizza alone
she was afraid she choked and no one
would be there that's not what made her
dumb she literally asked her what time
she goes she's gonna be a flight
attendant she goes does the Concorde is
that gonna be the sound of the speed of
light when they when they try can they
not hear anything I was like yeah yeah
that's right for the plane but they all
chalkboards rather next one are your
door cause I've done everything there is
to do in the world I've done it all
jumped out of a plane with Rachael Ray
found a bear I was the first person to
jump off the stratosphere jumped off the
world's tallest adium in Africa you name
it Travel Channel yeah farting impaired
was the dumbest thing I ever did I would
never do that again
you can't by the way so that the school
your daughter goes to they did have
father-daughter dances
yeah they do every year and you have to
go as a costume theme I remember when
you're and it's super creepy cuz you're
like wait it's couples then oh I already
know my costume well be Dane Cook and
his girlfriend you're paying for the
steam cleaning of this chair our next
guest Dame Judi Dench
[Applause]
like oh my lord what is this what
someone from Florida yeah did you know
that drinking I drink milk
edible cow did you know that's warm he
is shirtless and all the shows the funny
bone are sold out Bert Kreischer is here
this morning welcome back shirtless but
but I still have like a muffin top but I
think you feel good about your body
right you guys 40 and 44 but you lost 40
pounds I lost 40 pounds didn't do it
healthy but yeah I lost 40 pounds
well how does an exit ambien pop out at
the end of the day oh I'm hungry now I
take an ambien go to bed go to bed wake
up skinny south of all southern Ohio
Lakes is today so much different than
Cleveland right you mean like yeah the
place that the white people scare the
crap out of me there I got fired once I
was working for a shopping cart
manufacturer in uh in college and I was
working for the marketing division for a
[ __ ] person okay
[Laughter]